all right we are now
live and uh so it's AMA ask me anything
for October 2023 uh we're starting just
a little bit early because we've already
got some questions lined up and the
first one begins with a bit of a
misconception so this is from E deont
you said that you would consider
creating a bachelor's level curriculum
for a price some of us might be willing
to pay it could you give us a ballpark
estimate so I think you're laboring
under a misunderstanding or
misconception um when asked about
whether I would produce an entire
bachelor's curriculum I said no I would
not because that's not a good idea to
have only one person providing that what
I did say is that there all there are
already classes that you can take with
me online for a price
and you can find those in my study with
Sadler Academy sometimes they are
Standalone work at your own pace classes
sometimes I line up classes that meet
for you know eight weeks or four weeks
or however long and we do those online
and
synchronously um and I've been doing
that for years and years and years so I
have no intention of ever trying to
produce some sort of you know Dr sadders
Bachelor in philosophy curriculum
because I think it's a bad idea just to
have one person in on it and I don't
intend to produce a school that
coordinates a whole bunch of other
people um so you know there's no
ballpark estimate for that because it's
not something that's actually going to
happen but you can certainly take plenty
of classes with me if you want to um
you're just not going to get some sort
of accreditation or something like that
for it and uh e DeMont follows up saying
I asked chat GPT to create a bachelor's
level curriculum curriculum for a
Philosophy degree it created one
semester by semester it was interesting
you should try it and do a video on it I
probably won't do that um I don't really
do videos on chat GPT stuff in part
because the stuff that chat GPT produces
is usually full of errors and uh not
very good and when you point out that
it's making mistakes it continues making
new mistakes so uh I know a lot of
people are really fascinated with uh
what we call artificial intelligence
which is not actually intelligent at all
it's it's just algorithms doing their
things on you know data sets and stuff
like that that gives us the opportunity
and temptation to buy in and think that
we're dealing with
intelligence really not and um you know
I
mean ask an AI to create something that
it has no conception of when it's
basically just going to be drawing on
the sets of stuff that's already out
there why not just look directly at what
the curricula is for other um you know
uh what what professors have already
done and and what you're going to find
is that there's going to be a huge vast
variety it's not like there's a single
best curriculum for philosophy or ideal
curriculum or anything like that there
is zero consensus about that so all
right uh laps nine Continuum hi Dr
Sadler what's your take on the death
chapter and being in time I get the
sense that heiger thinks care and death
are essential opposites but that each
requires the possibility of the other so
I I don't think there's an actual death
chapter in the sense of just focusing on
death I think what you have in mind mind
is the section where being towards death
is being discussed and that's not the
same thing as death itself because you
know keep in mind what does heiger teach
us about death there your own death can
never actually be conceptualized right
that's a a key idea of this whole being
towards death concept that he is
deploying there and Care is deployed
throughout a number of different
sections of being in time zorga right in
in German and it's a really Central
concept you could translate it also as
concern right
and are is that an essential opposite to
death no I would say that's kind of a
category mistake they aspects of human
existence and you know you can have um
more care and less care care is
something that is fundamental but can be
covered over just as our being towards
death can as well um so you know I I
don't see them they they do involve each
other but like heiger says every
metaphysical question this is or every
metaphysical issue this is in what is
metaphysics involves all the rest of
them so it's not as if they are like
binary opposites that then are somehow
dialectically connected or something
along along those lines um so yeah um
Angry archae olist whose Channel I'm
going to check out actually because uh
they left a message saying or a comment
saying that they um were inspired by
what I was doing in part I'm sure
inspired by many other things as well to
do a similar kind of thing of their own
channel so I'm looking forward to
checking that
out have you ever had conversations
about the homeless with people and been
taken AB back by how quickly they
dehumanize them often they site their
assumed drug and alcoholic abuse as a
justification uh yeah I mean I've seen
that um including from some of my own
family members you know people that I
work with there's also people that are
like all about oh the poor homeless and
then they don't do a damn thing to help
them out as well right so um I mean you
could actually be somebody who has
negative attitudes towards the homeless
but goes out and gets them food or tents
or whatever it is um and you know you
would have a discrepancy there between
what you're saying and what you're doing
but what you're doing speaks louder I
think so yeah I've I've I've run into
plenty of people that are are like that
uh maximum uh did you read KAG guard's
repetition what did you think of it I
find it a bit of a strange book well
every book by kard is a bit of a strange
book Now isn't it I don't I don't think
kard has any books where you can say wow
this is a very normal book of philosophy
or theology so that's kind of a good
springboard right there for for thinking
about it um yeah I mean it's it's it's
an interesting work I mean I don't think
that ker guard's works all come together
as one sort of totally coherent
whole some people are more attracted
towards either or some towards fear and
trembling there are some big fans of
repetition out there who are like this
is the key to everything but I I don't
think there is a book that's a key to
everything in kirkgard so um yeah it's
it's it's good to read through right um
I mean my favorite book by kard is
philosophical fragments surprise
surprise right um but yeah repetition
it's it's one that uh I first
encountered in a kard reading group back
in graduate
school and um
you know it's it's good all right
[Music]
um let's see here so
sjs philosopher what's the most logical
explanation for why there's no US stamp
US coin or US currency that depicts
either Neil Armstrong face or his name I
don't know why do I care about that
that's not something that uh I would uh
care about and then uh yeah I'm gonna
actually uh uh skip the other silly
question about the Irish famine here as
well all right Ken uh good to see you
here Ken uh do you know if there will be
a fifth volume of stoicism today
collected writings very much enjoyed the
previous editions so I am not the editor
of stoicism today anymore or of the the
series but I can tell you that the
current editor who is my assistant
editor and good friend and colleague
Harold cley does in fact plan along with
uh his assistant editor Judith stove to
bring out um more volumes so there
should be a a volume Five and volume six
and the plan is just to continue on with
it and it'll be you know taking the the
better essays from that have been
published in stoicism today um over the
last couple years and putting them
together into a volume which then will
you know be sold through Amazon
publishing uh the the revenue from it
goes directly to the modern stoicism
organization which is the case for
volumes three and four which I and Leia
goldrick edited um one and two don't
though one and two the the proceeds from
that go to Patrick Usher who used to be
the uh editor he was the original editor
of the blog stoicism today so I think
that was part of his payment for it but
yeah there I'm glad that you've enjoyed
the volumes it's a lot of work putting
those together anytime you're doing an
edited volume you've got to coordinate a
lot of people and you got to stay on top
of a lot of things and I was very much
helped by the fact that I had um a
co-editor Leia goldrick who actually did
a lot of the layout work and some of the
contacting other authors and stuff like
that all right s which philosophers have
had the hardest swing from doing great
work to doing bad work and vice versa I
mean these are very
qualitative um things there there isn't
like a any more the like the definitive
philosophy curriculum there isn't going
to be a consensus on this I would say
and I I struggle to think of somebody
who really fits that
bill where you would say they were doing
great work at the start and now it's
really
bad um I mean you can say that some
people's stuff declines in quality so
you know for example I've talked about
this before daired do I think is a very
interesting example in his really early
work um he's doing quite
Innovative and very
careful um sort of you know attention to
the text things and he is being playful
but he's not it's not all about that so
I'm thinking about like on grammatology
and speech and phenomena and writing
indifference um and then he gets into
like this middle period where he's
become a star and he starts to I kind of
think believe the hype that's being said
about him and uh he starts you know
writing stuff that still got some rigor
to it sometimes but sometimes it's just
kind kind of a waste of time and then
towards the end of his life um maybe
like the last decade and a half he
starts paying more attention to politics
and religion and you know that's when we
see like this all this stuff like operas
and the gift of death and specters of
marks and politics of friendship um
which are which are quite
interesting but they weren't edited the
way that they ought to be so they're
they're basically all lectures that he's
giving and some of them are kind of
sprawling and rambling and you're like
it would have benefited having somebody
else's um eyes going over this and
saying H maybe this part goes maybe you
need to tighten this up um you know
people ask me about xek I often say that
xek when he first started out was quite
rigorous um and I actually in the 1990s
enjoyed reading his stuff but I don't
find him particularly interesting or
Illuminating much of the time these days
it's kind of hit and miss right um and I
think you can say that about a lot of uh
um recent Continental thinkers there's
this kind of you know you you get big
and then you um wind up uh getting away
with too much stuff and not like making
sure that people know where you're going
and why you're going there and um you
know people just kind of look at what
you're doing and buy into it now can we
think of any classical
uh philosophers where they started doing
work that wasn't very good towards the
mid end point of their career you know
it's interesting Maurice Merlo
Ponte the visible and the invisible is a
book that um quite a few Marlo Ponte
Scholars thought that um it wasn't you
know some people actually attributed to
him is like his brain not getting enough
oxygen he introduced a lot of new ideas
ideas and my mentor G Gillan who was a
maril laon scholar actually took the
opposite stand that it was sort of the
culmination of his work but yeah that
was a very
controversial position to take so I
don't know there's there's probably
quite a few that are are like that all
right um JMA you mentioned that you were
a huge Metal Head what would be your
favorite band or artist for the 80s 90s
and thousand I don't have favorites um I
have like those who are you know high up
there in the top tier I mean if you'd
asked me in the 80s who's your favorite
band I would have said Iron Maiden right
and Iron Maiden is still up there but I
would say on the same level with them
would be Judas Priest Motorhead Deep
Purple Black Sabbath Doo uh the
scorpians you know and then we can start
getting into to other things where
sometimes people are moving in and
moving out you know rat is up there for
me um sometimes I think that that kiss
deserves to be up there but then again
sometimes like Maybe not maybe really
great but not like super great um
and I don't think it would it would be
different for the 80s 90s and and
thousands I mean there were bands that I
got into that I wasn't into before in
those eras sometimes because they were
new bands right or newly recording bands
or I just hadn't heard of them before um
you know I I started listening to a lot
of alternative things in the the 90s and
of course there was the whole grunge era
right which is not metal but is kind of
adjacent to metal in some some respects
I mean there are some bands that are
kind of crossover like uh Allison Chains
right so there's there's quite a few
that that I I liked um from that time
there's also bands that I really got
into that are not metal um New Model
Army for example I really love their
stuff you know our Milwaukee the violent
fem who we got to see actually playing
with the Milwaukee Symphony Orchestra uh
La well earlier this week uh so I was
almost gonna say last week you know
there's there's quite a few great bands
out there and I'll also say something
too that we are really lucky here the
Milwaukee area in that we've got like
all these great concert venues and then
we've got Summerfest which in recent
years hasn't been great for metal but
like last year I got to take my my kid
and we saw vixon and autograph and
queens Reich and that was a lot of fun
and I've seen a lot of other great bands
there as
well um Magnus Ember says when you began
recording online lectures for the half
hour Hegel series did you find them more
difficult than in-person live lectures
did you have to change the pace or
structure of the lectures so I I I I
didn't start recording Hegel lectures
until
2014 and I was already
recording online lectures without a
class by
2012 you know I would just go into a
classroom set up my camera and start
recording so I I'd already done like
about I think 6
existentialism uh videos on figures like
haiger and sart and kamu and um uh kard
n shest all all these other
people and you know
shooting shooting at an event like when
you're doing public speaking or shooting
in a classroom where you're already in
the um sort of like teaching learning
context and you've got a live
audience I'd say that's a little bit
easier to do especially for for people
who um aren't aren't used to being on
their own so to speak and this is
actually a big problem during coid
that's why I produced a video called uh
something like Bare Bones advice for for
um producing videos you know to help
people out with that who didn't have a
lot of
experience but I I kind of found that
you know it didn't take me too long
to be pretty comfor fortable with
talking to an empty room because there's
the camera there right and you're
looking at it and you know that somebody
is going to be watching it and listening
to it you're not just talking into a
void um and so I had plenty of
experience by the time that I got to the
half hour Hegel now I will say this the
half hour Hegel videos could be more
difficult than some other texts right so
you know it's a close reading not
skipping anything that can be kind of
tough and Hegel is a very difficult
writer as well so I you know I would put
in you know on average about five hours
to produce each half hour Hegel video
sometimes less sometimes more i' you
know take the text and reread it and put
things on the chalkboard and think about
what I wanted to say and you know
sometimes i' I'd come up with examples
you could say on the fly um and so
that's you know that can be kind of
difficult
um I will say that you know going back
to the original
texts you know the original language is
very important for a lot of uh the
thinkers that I I work on so you know
like when I did my videos on
heraclitis I've only done I think four
of them so far uh core concept videos
I'm going back to the Greek and I'm
looking at it and trying to figure out
well what exactly is being said here
right and so that that takes time um the
videos I'm shooting on a manual con PR
not any future metaphysics I you know
I've got the German text and I'm going
back and forth between the uh uh hacket
translation and um the the original text
and seeing what I need to to put in
there and so that that adds a bit of
difficulty I would say right um so yeah
good question uh
all
right dii and Le how do we interpret
works that have some parts which are not
falsifiable or empirical like the 12
categories of understanding by con oh
boy if you think that um everything
needs to be empirical or falsifiable
because things can be empirical without
being
falsifiable boy are you narrowing the
scope of philosophy and you want to
think about why you're making such a
massive sweeping unjustified assumption
like that the answer is probably
somebody taught you that and you didn't
like really question it very much and
Now's the Time to question it right
there are all all sorts of things that
go beyond the completely empirical that
won't be easily or perhaps even in
principle falsifiable and yet are
meaningful and yet can be thought of so
um that's it's all it's kind of a non
question I think you want to like think
about your own assumptions moving into
that one
all right Mark good to see you here uh
hope you're well will you be supporting
the sa spring box in the title defense
of the Rugby World Cup 2031 is coming to
the USA uh gonna watch a a game live um
I mean I don't really know much about
rugby never played it um never really
watched it so I mean if they if they
make it in there I suppose I could root
for them as we say um
I'm assuming that's the South African
like national team um so you know sure I
I could I could do that but my my
commitment is rather lukewarm you could
say right um I mean the only sports
teams that I really pay that much
attention to are in NFL football and AHL
hockey because we have the Admirals here
the hockey team and we have um you know
our uh Packers and I'm also a Bears fan
Chicago Bears some people think you you
can't do that but here I am a living
contradiction um all right uh Luca do
you think Plato's conception of love as
it appears in the Symposium or fedis are
applicable to our relationships nowadays
uh and it's good that you put it in
plural yeah conceptions of love because
um Love is articulated in in multiple
ways in these different speeches in the
Symposium and in the fadis where it it's
also being communicated through speeches
either dialogue between Socrates and
fedis or Socrates giving a speech or
lissus give you know reading a speech by
lissus and all that yeah I mean there's
lots of different conceptions of love
and different people operate according
to different things I mean that that I
mean do we really want to buy like the
whole discourse of
Aristophanes about like we were cut down
the middle originally we had four arms
four legs two heads probably not right
uh that's that's all mythical stuff but
the idea of us being drawn to um our
missing half that's kind of a beautiful
idea isn't it so you know nothing wrong
with that I would say um and uh you know
what's good about it is we can we can
take all these different conceptions of
love you know take for example um love
understood in a physical way and I don't
mean physical as like erotic desire but
as um how the elements are harmonized or
disharmonize in Eric simic's account in
the Symposium you see others criticizing
this in subsequent speeches right so
yeah I I would say that this stuff is
useful I don't know that it's always the
best model you you know um but it
certainly provides us with some models
that we can examine and then apply in
our own life
right
um let's see oh Gilbert Bates says this
is not a philosophical question as such
doesn't have to be
philosophical uh I struggle with my ego
a lot especially when I want people to
think that I'm intelligent but also
sometimes with people thinking that I'm
funny so it's not so much ego but rather
self-image and and you want people to
see you in the way that you would also
like to see yourself right uh so this is
kind of an ideal um and I think there's
lots of people like that and I don't I
don't think that any of us are
completely Beyond or free of that I mean
it if I go into a classroom and I'm
teaching my students and it just doesn't
connect that doesn't feel good if I
think that they think who the hell is
this idiot up here in front of the truck
Board Writing stuff down just saying
stupid random things that's that's not
fun right um so I think
that's in one respect it's normal then
the question is like well how invested
are you in people seeing you in certain
ways and you know how realistic are the
uh the ways in which you you view
yourself and would like to be viewed by
others um and you know there's often a
lot of cases where people might actually
think better of us than than we are you
know prime example of this is so when
we're reading a philosophical work so I
actually you know I got out being in
time just to like look through a little
bit and see is there actually a chapter
on death I don't remember there being
one so you know you think of a big thick
book like this or hegel's phenomenology
or starts being a nothingness or pick
whatever else you want so they didn't
write the whole damn thing all at once
and it's not as if like you can
translate okay what's here in the head
and what's here in the book the book is
an artifact that represents you know
years and years and years of thinking
and um I mean we can say the same thing
with Plato's dialogues and Aristotle
treates and decart's
meditations um we're always getting
something that is presenting a kind of
image so we're like man this guy's
brilliant I disagree with him on these
things but holy crap look at the depth
of thought that doesn't mean that like
heiger every single day is on like that
um you know we create illusions that way
and I would say my YouTube channel does
that as well because you can see me
giving all sorts of lectures on all
sorts of philosophers and you could
think that wow if I could just like hang
out with him you know he's he's doing
philosophy all the time no I mean I'm
doing philosophy when I'm doing
philosophy sometimes I'm eating you know
a meal and watching a TV show sometimes
I'm reading some sci-fi sometimes I'm
just hanging out with cats at the cat
shelter all of our lives are like that
right so I would say you know the thing
to do is is to just think about um what
you're struggling with what what is it
that you how is it that you want people
to see you and why you know why is it
causing you um anxiety or grief or you
know other negative emot emotions we can
feel anger too yeah you don't see me the
way I want to be seen right
so all right uh Manu Vargis what are
your thoughts on AI platforms like chat
GPT or Bard for learning philosophy I
think it's a mistake to use them um I
mean it's cutting
Corners I mean you could use it for like
maybe trying to generate prompts or
something like that but but it's a lazy
person's way of trying to make sense of
things um and it's foolish too because
artificial intelligence as I remarked
earlier is not intelligent and to think
that it is is setting yourself up for
all sorts of problems you know um I mean
you could you could ask it to give you a
list of you know 20 philosophers you
ought to read but what you're getting
there is not any intelligent thing
saying that it's just a mish mash of a
bunch of things it took from here and
there and it's probably reflective of
whatever sources it used and
uncritically uh assimilated and and you
know sort of smushed together so I would
say you're actually I mean if you want
to use it as a a
tool maybe that's fine but you really
want to do your own research and
thinking and connecting with other
people rather than relying on um
something to be shortcuts or Corner
cutting for yourself uh back mooon what
do you who do you think are the most
interesting Marxist philosophers a lot
of people I talk to tend to gravitate to
Alto Z gromi but of course there's many
others like
adorno I mean I think adoro is very
interesting I've never really gotten
into all two Zer I've tried reading him
before gromi is okay um I mean I I'm not
interested in people identifying
themselves as marxists because like with
a lot of philosophers there's a very
much like a team M you know kind of
thing going along with it that I think
actually gets in the way of doing good
philosophy I think that Marx has
interesting contributions to make but um
I don't know that being a Marxist is
really the the thing to do right um You
can certainly acknowledge what Marx has
to say and and you know the parts of it
that are interesting or useful uh and
then say but you know not everything
fits into this this nice uh way of of
arranging things and um you know not
everything proceeds according to this
this historical dialectic the way that
that they make it out to be so I think
Marxism uh often winds up being
something that's more useful in
conjunction with other things and you
could say well I mean that's what adorno
is doing Marxism and Freud and some n
and some other some Hegel and other
things yeah um that's why adorno isn't
like a typical Marxist right
um that's probably enough about about
that one all
right
um Marco how would you suggest to start
with
Freud probably the introductory lectures
I mean they're Freud's idea of an
introduction to his his work um I've
done a few videos on a few of them right
um I mean you could you could jump in
really wherever you want you could read
you know shorter things like jokes in
the unconscious there's of course the
big you know on the interpretation of
Dreams which is good to read there's
case studies there isn't like a one
single place to start with Freud I would
I would say I mean the one thing I can
say is picking any one of the works
don't turn it into the foundational work
that you take as like the key to
interpreting Freud throughout all of his
works because Freud is is a thinker
who's engaged with many many other
thinkers his thought is evolving over
time as well through his practice
through his engagement with his
colleagues estrangement and alienation
from other colleagues you know um so you
you just don't want to put too much
weight on any one single work um all
right
uh D defective dunan says do you have
any plans on doing some videos on the
aspect Emperor books by our Scott backer
cheers from
Sweden um not for this coming year of
Worlds of speculative fiction I might do
it the next time around what I what I
discovered when I tried to
do a session on the first set so we're
talking about a seven book series at
this point in time there's a Trilogy and
then a I guess what
quadrilogy uh quater or something like
that and the first three are the uh
Prince of nothing ones and then we have
the aspect Emperor ones right and um
backer was was supposed to write some
more as well to bring the series to a
close because a little bit of a spoiler
the aspect Emperor series after this
very long slog we go through it has a
heart wrenching ending uh to the the
seventh book the fourth book in in that
group so when I when I started doing the
first three I I was gonna do them in a
single session and I was like oh man
that's not gonna work I got to do one
session on each of these because there's
just so much stuff each of them is like
in over 500 pages there's so many themes
built into them it's very philosophical
because the guy was in fact a a
philosophy graduate student when he
wrote the first one one right he was
working on his dissertation which he
never did
finish
um so you know it took a lot to do that
I do like the aspect Emperor uh four
book
series and I was thinking because I I
have given some thought to this what if
I did like the first two as one session
and then the second two as another
session because I don't want to take
onethird of the year to go through the
whole of of that
and I might do that but I I already have
some stuff lined up for uh 2024 I've
already got some stuff picked out um and
uh so if I was going to do it it'
probably be in
2025 and maybe by then you know backer
actually comes out of
his his whatever you want to call it
retirement uh uh hiding and produces the
other books which i' I'd love to
see um
all right uh let's see
here um uncontrollable greatness what is
your favorite dialogue by by Plato I
again I don't think I have a favorite
dialogue I mean I I there's some that I
enjoy for reading and thinking about
there's some that I really enjoy
teaching
um and they overlap to a significant
amount um I mean I do love the Symposium
it's a great work I actually got to read
it for an entire semester with with a
guy who'd been reading it for 40 years
in Greek you know and go over it Point
by Point by Point um and that was a lot
of fun um obviously the Republic is is
very important but I find parts of it
kind of a a
slog um I do like the gorgeous quite a
bit and uh you know I need to do some
more videos on that I did a few for my
anger
class um I mean the fedo has grown on me
I I I used to not like the fat quite so
much but it's grown on me over time in
part because I see the connections so
maybe this is what to say um I like
seeing the connections between the
dialogues not just the dialogues for
themselves but what they they they touch
on and I would say that that's something
that the you know Plato
followers um the uh particularly the the
later platinus that we call neop
platinus I think they they kind of like
that as well you know all right
um Zach says in my experience messing
with chat GPT it often gets things wrong
and gives madeup references yeah that
that's the big problem I mean you really
have to know what you're doing in chat
GPT it's sort of like knowing whether a
translation is good or not if you can't
read the original you got to trust the
uh reviewers or stuff like that except
that with chat GPT it's just making
stuff up on the fly so unless you
actually know the field asking it about
stuff is probably not going to be all
that helpful for you
right um Ellie attic have you ever
considered doing live debates uh sure
I've considered it and uh not done it
because I'm I'm not into debating people
debates usually are a waste of time and
a lot of posturing and typically don't
convince people who are you know
supposedly on the fence and they they
often bring out the worst in people I
understand that they're you know big
engagement things but I I think you know
most debates don't have they're not very
interesting you know except for gotcha
moments and and how much mileage are we
going to get out of that as mature
people you know um
laps n Continuum did you ever teach
younger children I just had my first day
oh man substituting third grade it was a
little
chaotic no I I don't teach I don't teach
uh kids or high schoolers or anything
like that and uh more power to you if
you can put up with that I mean I've
done a few guest lectures here and there
but I do not want to govern a classroom
you know and plus you got to deal with
all the the the BS educational theory
that the they teach in um as if it's you
know dogmatically right in uh education
curricula um that can be a little bit
wearing as well so no but I I do have
quite a bit of respect for people who
can teach children well because man is
that an
important function in our society right
so um oh here's another one so laps nine
Continuum said uh hoping to advance my
career into teaching math eventually any
general
advice well yeah I mean if you're here
in the United States um we're one of the
few places
where people make these silly excuses
because it's part of our culture towards
Academia that oh I'm just not good at
math right as if math isn't something
that you can get better at by you know
doing what you would do with anything
else like
practicing uh trying to you know take a
more active role in your your learning
and work and stuff like that so I would
be on the the lookout for kids who have
been told by their parents or other
teachers that they're just not good at
math and say Hey you know I wasn't good
at uh playing the pick whatever
instrument but then I practice and now I
am good at it or you know I learned a
foreign language or math is B basically
like that it's not something where like
you just have a talent for it and uh
some people have it and some people
don't now you know of course some people
can visualize things better and figure
out how to solve problems better but um
hard work is is definitely an important
part of it right so all right uh sisifus
says what translation of hegel's
phenomenology do you think is the best
um and I'm going to give a joking answer
because I'm sure you're asking about
English translations but you know there
is this guy hippolite Jean hippolite who
wrote uh a great commentary on hegel's
uh phenomenology of spirit and
translated the phenomenology of spirit
into French two volumes why is it two
volumes because it is like filled with
footnoted discussions by hippolite about
um what saying in this this place or
that place that's kind of a cool thing
right um so there there uh there are
five English translations readily
available now and you know the standard
used to be the Miller
translation which is not the best but
it's not it's not bad that's what we cut
our teeth on um uh it had replace the
Bailey translation which had been a
standard for for quite a while and then
in the
last three four
years there's been uh three new
translations that that have come out um
of which I've looked at parts of them
and I'm most familiar with the Pinker
translation which I I I I really do like
I I um got a hold of uh when he was
first putting them out pinkards like
drafts for that that stuff because I
needed the the German text um and uh I
think that Pinker is a good
translator um I get the other two a bit
mixed up in my head you can go to the um
uh self-directed study in Hegel video
where I actually talk about each of
these translations English
translations um one of them is one of
the recent ones is not really that good
it's kind of weird the way it's set up
and it doesn't number the paragraphs
which I think is not particularly
helpful um but I I I would you know if I
were going to start a new like let's say
I was going to do the half hour Hegel
series from the beginning I would
probably take pinker's
translation uh Milan philosophers Corner
hope you're doing well I'm doing okay
I'm having some health issues uh having
to do with uh gallbladder stuff that's
uh you might have seen on social media
gives me some pain but the pain is uh
mild to moderate and manageable so you
know this is what happens when you have
a body that's getting
older um uncontrollable greatness which
poets or poet should a beginner of
poetry start with I don't know um that
is not in my wheelhouse so to
speak I only teach poetry when it has to
do with philosophy so you know for
example rainor Maria rila right um but I
I don't really know that much about
poetry as such and I don't know where
you would start I don't know if there is
a where you would start with poetry
quite frankly that that'd be a good
question for like a literature person
not quite so much for for
me um
clug sorry if this is asked a million
times what are you planning on to
succeed your half hour Hegel series is a
long-term project
so um I'm going to keep doing the half
hour close reading starting with
passages and then commenting on them
probably at at the
chalkboard and the next text that I'm
going to do is a much shorter
text by anom of Canterbury the person
who I've published the most on in the
course of my career somebody who I like
quite a bit and I'm G to be doing his
prian and the reason I'm doing that is
because you know most people if they
read ansom They're basically only
reading uh a little bit of
um uh the prian chapter two or maybe
chapter two through four because it's
got the so-called ontological argument
for God's existence which it's not
really a a good uh designator for it for
reasons you'll see when when we we get
to it because the entire work minus the
final three chapters which are
conjecture
is one single argument an Unum
argumentum including the prayer in In
chapter one right um so I'm going to do
that uh and then after that the plan is
to do a a very close attentive reading
of decart's
meditations uh which is we're going to
be looking at the Original Latin uh
which is what deart wrote it in and then
the French translation and of course the
English uh Adam and Tannery text right
um am I mixing that
up yeah a little bit uh Adam and Tanner
is the the U complet right anyway uh
we're going to do day cart's meditations
and then I'm GNA decide on another big
thick book like you know the hegel's
phenomenology and I'm not doing the
logic because there's already people who
who are doing videos on that you know
Stephen Holgate gave a whole series of
lectures to the uh Bri the Hegel Society
of Britain that are available on on
YouTube now there's you know no
chalkboard or anything but you can you
can listen to them so I don't I don't
think that I need to do the the logic
somebody else is doing that right um but
you know I might do like Jean Paul sarts
being a nothingness I think that's an
interesting text and it's one that I
that was like the first really big
philosophy book that I read as an
undergraduate and I was just fascinated
with it so I that could be kind of good
and sarch is fun to read too in both
English translation and in French so
that's probably what I'll be
doing all right um Milan says how are
the cats so I'm assuming you mean the
cats at almost home uh cat Refuge uh
where I volunteer occasionally and often
go in on open houses on on Sundays I
mean they're doing good you know it's
it's a place where cats are continually
being fostered or adopted out that is
the purpose of having the cat shelter uh
it's not to you know just us volunteers
go in and hang out with them forever and
so there's there's an aspect of you have
to like love them and take care of them
and give them attention and affection
while they're there and then they go and
and there's somebody else's cats and
they probably don't remember you very
long but you made an impact in their
their little lives and uh it's it's nice
for you know it's nice for the cats it's
nice for me it's nice for the people who
come in to check out the cats and and
maybe you know spend some time with them
themselves and even consider adopting
them or fostering them so um yeah
something I've wanted to do for quite a
while after uh sassy my uh closest
animal companion died about a year and a
half ago you know I thought well that's
that's what I'll do to get my cat fixed
and um you know almost home is great
it's it's they're very very
conscientious the staff all know what
they're doing it's uh I I'm willing to
say it's the best shelter in the
Milwaukee area and perhaps in the
midwest you know because it's it's
actually run by people who really really
know what they're doing
so all right uh El elatic do you think
children should study philosophy or
logic early on it couldn't hurt right I
mean how to get that into the curriculum
that's the tricky part I mean here in
America and I can't speak for other
places you know a lot of other places if
you're gonna go on the University
preparation track you're going to get
some philosophy right uh here in America
probably not much and if it's taught in
high school it'll be as like a social
science or or um English elective or
sometimes a religion elective in
religious schools but it is it is tough
to get in and and we have a lot of
schools where they're cutting things
like music and art you know so making a
case for philosophy is Pretty
Tough all right um Kus maybe a better
question is just uh whe is just whether
you think with what chat GPT is doing is
at all univocal with what we do in terms
of writing or
intelligence um I don't think that we
can even use those terms like analogical
or univocal or equivocal because chat
GPT doesn't understand language so you
can't really intend a meaning of a term
when you don't even know what you're
working with chat GP chat GP is not
conscious doesn't have intentions it's
just uh an engine that is very complex
and fools us when we allow ourselves to
be fooled into thinking that there's
something more going on than there there
is you know I think I missed something
oh uh Johan Sig and Raphael's Fresco the
School of Athens why does Aristotle
point to the ground and Plato the
heavens I mean I think the uh
traditional thing is Aristotle is about
empiricism and Plato about idealism you
know look look at the stuff that's
actually here no turn your your gaze to
the heavens which as we know these are
um in part true in part false you know I
mean Aristotle is not the anytime we set
up these real strong dichotomies they
usually turn out to be false uh when you
when you look at their
texts
um let's
see ELO says hello I'm having a bit of
difficulty with hum's definition of idea
do you have an easy way to differentiate
the ideas and Impressions I have a whole
video on it um just Google you know Hume
idea Impressions and and I've got a core
concept video um discussing that
um Stephen Warren says I saw you mention
making a series on sickness onto death
off the top of your head what are some
of the philosophical Concepts you find
most important from this work well
obviously despair right I mean that
that is really one of the central
question or Central issues in the work
that is the sickness onto death um and
then you know how how we can be in
despair without realizing it draws
pretty on kard and kind of reworks
Concepts and that that notion of Despair
and not knowing that you're in despair I
mean that's kind of similar to what's
going on in haider's uh conrol of how we
conceal our anxiety from ourselves and
you know things things like that
so um let's see
here
elatic do you think philosophy reveals
something mystical about language what I
mean is when I read heiger what is
metaphysics I started to realize that in
question is in the question I don't
think you have to get me mystical about
that and and the word mystical I think
is not a particularly useful one except
in very specific contexts in philosophy
because people use it to mean everything
from
like here's my gut sense about stuff and
I just can't explain it perhaps because
I'm not articulate enough to you know
here is the hidden revelation that has
been there from the very beginning the
Creator placed it in the world and
everything in between right so I don't
usually use this term mystical very
often because I I find it leads to
misunderstandings you
know
um let's see AB Raman Naser says thanks
for doing this all this time and it's
been great help for me I'm glad glad to
read it that's that's good
um all right uh milhan says I'd like to
adopt a Persian cat eventually yeah
there's lots of different kinds of cats
um I don't think I'd want a Persian
because their faces are kind of smoed in
and I think that um breeding animals so
that they have a lower quality of life
because of the way that their bodies are
set up is it's not something actually
want to be part of and encourage you
know
so
um but there's you know there's plenty
of Persian cats out there already so
they need love too
right um clug says yes the only thing
thing I know about anom is the
ontological argument in gilo's objection
well then you don't know anything about
anom because it's not an ontological
argument in the sense that like the
later things that Kant identified as
ontological arguments found in deart and
Spinosa uh have been presented and um
gelo's objection is there's actually
like you know page after page after page
of that and then anom actually has has
responses to gilo and by the way ansom
required that people who copy the text
should copy the objections and his
replies too uh Francisco says would you
recommend any specific work to start
with
kard
um I mean I think it's better to start
with a shorter work than a longer one
pro so you don't want to like use either
or which is quite
long but there's lots of ways to go into
his stuff you know I would say sickness
onto death but it's got it begins with
that crazy paragraph that tends to
discourage people at the beginning right
about the relation and the relation to
the relation and all that so you know I
mean what do I usually start people out
on fear and trembling because um it's
it's you know it's talking about
particular characters I think it's easy
to connect to it's got this whole
interesting discussion of like the night
of infinite resignation and the night of
Faith um there's some cool side
discussions in there it poses this this
uh problem of Abraham uh very
clearly then again we could start with
philosophical fragments which I think is
a really great and and quite coherent
work um I mean he's he's got a lot of
other uh cool works as well but I don't
think there's one that you have to start
with
uh which would be like the best one you
know uh Gilbert Bates what is something
most people Miss from being in
nothingness as it what is the blind
spotter idea that most people Miss I
mean most people don't read being in
nothingness and if they talk about it
they've usually only read parts of it so
there's gonna be big blind spots um just
from not being all that familiar with
it
um that's a good
question
so you know the the issue of the other
is really centrally important and this
is something that Gabriel Marcel
criticized
sness for this
um is is s setting things up in such a
way as your relation to the other can
never really be a let's call it a good
one right
um I don't think so I think there's
there's room for it in there but I think
a lot of people they you know look at
the things that where sard is actually
making really nicely worked out analyses
about how the other you know is like
objectifying us and we're objectifying
them
um you know actually I'm going to say a
different thing though one thing that
people very often get wrong about s
because you know people love sound bites
and quotes and stuff like that is um
hell is other people and that is
something that is said by one of the
characters in no exit right and it's not
asserted as like sart thinks that this
is exactly what we what we mean right
and
[Music]
um it's it's you know perhaps his view
perhaps not but it's better to look at
it as hell as other people if you're
stuck with the kind of people who wind
up down in this this hell it's not a
universal statement about The Human
Condition um and its possibilities it's
saying wow for a lot of people they
really do make that their own life and
other people's life hellish right so
it's important to to bring context to to
things all right
um curio says to be a philosophy
Professor or lecturer do you have to be
well-versed in all basic areas of
philosophy for example if one wants to
specialize in Buddhist philosophy do
they still need to know the history of
philosophy have a good grasp on logic I
mean the answer to that is no I mean
there's plenty of philosophy professors
if we're talking about people who
actually teach philosophy and have
university positions who are not
well-versed in the history of philosophy
I mean most people in analytic
philosophy have very little grasp on the
history of philosophy right or most
basic areas of philosophy they have like
their little thing that they do and
that's that's about it uh most
philosophy professors don't know much
about Buddhism let alone Buddhist
philosophy where we're talking about
like very complex uh analyses of things
in particular Buddhist schools that have
developing over centuries and centuries
and like I don't I don't have the the
language capacities to read things in in
poly or classical Chinese or Sanskrit or
any any of these other things you know
um we're all you know there I actually
did a whole thing about this in one of
my quick takes people who get worried
about being well- read none of us are
well
read in the sense of like knowing all
the the stuff it's just a matter of um
you know thinking it it through and and
uh acquiring some map of how things fit
together but um nobody can actually read
more more than just a sliver of what's
available let alone study it right and
uh so no you I mean you may be mistaking
to be a philosophy professor and then to
be the ideal of a philosophy Professor
now if you're asking about that you
probably do need to know quite a few
things right
um but yeah Tanner says what do you
think of flat ontologies I don't know
that term so I don't think anything of
it
um let's see here elatic do you think
that being a human is a trait depends on
what you mean by trait you know that
word is used in a lot of different ways
what's the specific uh technical context
I mean I think if you're a human you're
a human so it's not really a trait as as
the way we typically understand the term
but maybe there's some weird
philosophical discourse in which that's
that's uh that makes sense to
say um
Johan Sig I've heard s dismissed before
is essentially stealing from rewriting
being in time how wrong is this are
there some bits that are mere
transformations of heiger not truly
original so you you've got the question
framed the wrong way there is nothing
that is truly original you know I mean
the more you research things the more
you're going to find antecedants and
you're going to find people engaging
with others and originality is kind of a
a trap
um people worry way tooo much about that
um the question isn't whether you're
you're taking other people's ideas the
question is what are you doing with them
and yeah there's there's things that I
mean if you read starts being a
nothingness he will say heiger says and
here's what I'm doing with that so
obviously there are some things that
he's taking from heiger and from beone
and from Hagel and from dayart you know
um and if you read haiger haiger
sometimes will tell you stuff like that
as well you know here we're going to
take this thing that we we figured out
from Hegel or
Kant um now anybody who says things like
he's essentially stealing from or
rewriting and being in time those people
are kind of lazy Scholars uh and there's
a lot of that out there in the world um
you know some of them are teaching in in
philosophy positions and they you know
have their nice little quips and it it
makes their world nice and easy because
then they don't have to like read heiger
or start
attentively um but it's wrong right so
when people say stuff like that to you
you should probably be like I don't know
about this guy who's saying this sort of
thing you know I mean we may as well say
well Merlo ponti is basically just you
know redoing uh huso you know and and uh
um Aristotle's basically just like
reacting against Plato and and you know
it's all footnotes to Plato I mean
people say stuff like that because
people say all sorts of stupid things
right and then they catch on because
they're easy quips but those are things
that get in the way of actually like you
know thinking things through
so all right pipeline I wonder if the
Christian Trinity in any way could be
modeled after the ancient stoics and
others conception of the virtues
constituting a Unity um I don't know why
you would want to um I mean if you know
you could quite easily go to St
Augustine if you want models for the
trinity
he he's going to give you lots of them
you know so um I don't know why you'd
want to reinvent wheels that uh
definitely don't don't need it because
there's other people who've already
written about it at at Great length I
mean for Augustine it's not going to be
about the cardinal virtues because
that's obviously not a trinity is it uh
that's that's uh four of them um and
actually Augustine doesn't think that
the virtues are the the best thing
anyway if you read city of God for
example Le um so you know I I think if
you're going to try to conceptualize the
Trinity which is a difficult thing to do
first you want to actually see what
other people have had to say about it
Augustine has a whole book on the
Trinity um and then you know if you want
to go past those people and try to
figure out stuff for your own you want
to think
about analogies that will involve three
things rather than than four or two or
20 or or whatever
right um Zachary if Socrates was on a
philosophic mission from God why did he
spend his time trying to refute the god
this seems impious rather than Pious yes
as we point out every time we teach the
text and as I've talked about in my my
video on um the apology and Socrates
Divine Mission sure um I mean what you
ought to be thinking about is how can I
think my way past this because obviously
there is a a paradox here so how what
sort of constru can I come up with that
has Socrates actually trying to do this
as something that he views as Pious how
could that in fact makes sense
right
um all right uh Ali aad why don't you
make a series on ciceros tusculan
disputations why don't you uh bankroll
them and uh commission me to do them you
know I mean people are always telling me
what I ought to be doing and uh the
simple answer
is I got a lot of stuff to do right now
I'm working on K uh pra to any future
metaphysics and then I probably got to
do some more things on the business
ethics text that I'm teaching and cico
is great and the tusil in disputations
are great but it's not a high priority
for me right now and if you want it to
go up in priority
anybody at any time can write me and say
hey I'm willing to pay for your work and
time because I really want to see this
people have done that with n texts and
heiger texts and Plato stuff in the past
you know if you're really itching to see
a particular thing you know reach out to
me and say uh I wanna I want to
underwrite this you
know
um let's see
here
kuhan
Panka would you ever consider making a
reading and commentary of Lan's work as
you've done with hegel's phenomenology I
mean I I've thought about doing that
with two things with the uh ethics of
psychoanalysis which I might do as core
concept videos because I I think that's
a particularly accessible way to get
into Lan's stuff or you know the
full and that would be a huge huge
project and you know people would have
to be willing to Pony up and and help
fund that that sort of work because this
is you know taking doing the half hour
Hegel project it was supported by
patreon um I'm so happy that people
thought it was valuable enough to to
help me with that because every one of
those things is a ton of work right and
um if you like good stuff you got to
support it you know it's kind of kind of
an important
thing um
Ali Awad what do you think of Victor
Franco's logo therapy and man's search
for meaning and his existential views of
meaning so logo therapy is not really
contained in man search for meaning man
search for meaning is a popular work
that Franco wrote and I I was really
quite surprised because you know I read
that back when I was in college of
course you know uh when we were talking
about existentialism everybody reads
Franco uh at one point or another and
it's it's not a bad work and it's got
some
interesting things to it but Franco I
actually wrote a lot of other works in
uh Psychotherapy and
psychology and those are way more
developed and way more rigorous so if
you want to find logo therapy you don't
find it so much in man search for
meaning that's the popularization the
sort of like appetizer the meal are his
other work which I I think are actually
quite quite interesting um and and we're
fortunate that we have a bunch of them
over in the uh uh Central Library here
in Milwaukee now it's been a couple
years since I read them so I couldn't
tell you all that much about it at this
point in
time uh elatic is
uh example vegans would say humans
aren't very different from other animals
when it comes to traits again don't know
what uh and that's what they would use
to justify veganism well vegans use all
sorts of things to justify veganism I
mean some some of their arguments are
pretty pretty crap and some of them are
more interesting than
others
um let's see here elatic the Eastern
view of the Trinity there is no Eastern
view of the Trinity there are Eastern
views of the Trinity and every once in a
while somebody who's claiming to be
Eastern because the or the Eastern
Orthodox are not the only Eastern
Christians right we also have
how many other churches that are also
Oriental Orthodox and they have their
own theologies and their own liturgies
um there is no like Eastern View in that
way so um pipeline I meant how the
Trinity Doctrine first came into
existence oh well then you got to do
some historical research because the the
Trinity Doctrine took you know a while
to evolve and you're going to have a lot
of reading ahead of you to if you want
to think about that right uh it's not
coming from stoic virtues uh Andy almost
a Scottish philosopher oh good good to
see you I I've been meaning to get back
to I've just been tied up with all of my
uh uh health issues as of lately um uh
glad you're well I was wondering if you
think a connection could be made between
the punk attitude and the existential
attitude themes such as
anti-institutional ISM authentic
belonging I mean we could also raise the
DIY right which was really Central to uh
classical 70s and 80s punk as well um
and you know sort of stripping things
down and talking about the things that
really matter to
you um and I wonder too I mean Punk was
in it's Origins associated with a a kind
of youth culture as well and some people
wanted to say Punk is nistic but I think
you could say that like a lot of
existentialist work um
neoism is framed as a situation and a
problem right but it's not the
solution um and it would be interesting
like what if we took
um contemporary Punk not just music but
like cultural artifacts like Repo Man
the movie right and we say okay this is
definitely is a movie about a a bunch of
punks does this have existentialist
themes to it can we connect these
together I I don't think we can like say
that you know Punk is the existentialism
of the 70s and 80s or anything like that
but um I think we can say there's a lot
of
connections between them right um so
that that's kind of a cool idea right
Ken is weighing in here I wouldn't say
Punk was nealis definitely a
counterculture though in a similar way
to early New Wave of British heavy metal
where there also were some some punk
influences right coming in um yeah I
mean I mean you you could be a punk
rocker and be a nealis jerk who's just
exploiting people and you know um
screwing people over and stuff like that
because you're like there is no meaning
man right but every every
musical um movement has those those
people right the exploiters but if
you're really if you're really thinking
about what does it mean to live an
authentic life and you're like um well I
don't want to be one of those squares
you know but you're like well but I but
I have to work how am I going to
reconcile these things together those
are some uh those are some
really interesting themes and notice how
we can do philosophy thinking about
these sorts of questions um to go back
to some of the earlier things that
people were asking
about particularly with like younger
people
um sometimes we do well not just to try
to do philosophy thematically and be
like okay today we're talking about
Aristotle you
know sometimes it's it's bringing things
in and you know may feel like pandering
to some people but I I think getting
people
interested in how we can read our our
cultural situation and popular culture
through classical philosophical ideas is
is a you
know quite
useful all right
uh laps 9 continum I used to work in an
animal shelter so glad to hear almost
home there in Milwaukee is run by the
right people that's a huge problem yeah
yeah yeah that's a huge problem
throughout shelters more generally yeah
this is a problem with volunteer
organizations in general is you often
don't get people who are in it for the
right reasons right um and because
they're volunteers sometimes they're
like well I get to give whatever I want
like at almost home we are so the board
is required to be contributors not just
like running the show but they all have
to be making monthly
contributions um to the
shelter and they're expected to do a lot
of work I'm not a board member I'm just
a
volunteer and I do two things I help out
at the uh open houses and with cleaning
and I'm on the grants committee along
with my wife helping to try to find
money for almost home and I'm you know
I'm required like all the other
volunteers to put in at least six hours
each month with the cats cleaning litter
you know feeding them checking them
doing all that that sort of stuff right
um and uh I think that's that's part of
the way that you got to go and and we
had to complete classes on fear-free
fear free
shelters um you you got to do you know
like orientation and all that that kind
of like weeds the the people out who
wouldn't be quite so good and one thing
I do want to say about this
shelter is that it was founded by people
who had worked in other
shelters and saw what didn't work in the
other shelters and they were like we we
need to do it right we want to have a
shelter that is not making this mistake
this mistake this mistake and and a lot
of that has to do with like
seemingly mundane things like you got to
keep it clean there's just no way once
cats start
marking you're not going to get that
scent out of there and it's just going
to be a problem going forward you can
pressure wash cages and things like that
or enclosures but you're never going to
get that cat you're in Scent completely
gone or if you allow there to be
diseases that are breaking out you're
not quarantining
animals um you're going to have problems
and it'll it'll spread throughout the
entire the entire shelter right so
staying on top of that kind of mundane
stuff these people are are really good
at that and so that's why I wanted to um
get involved I mean I I first started
going to open houses and I I was like
holy crap these people know what they're
doing you know and then I was like I
want to be part of this organization
so all right
um Chris see how can someone know if
they're being authentic with thems there
isn't like a single criteria for that um
it's probably easier to realize where
you're not being authentic because you
have a sense of like well I'm lying
about myself here um I don't know that
that you necessarily have to have a I
know that I'm being authentic I think
it's on kind of a Continuum right and
something you got to like rework over
and over again too so Mark says watch
Gard Alphaville recently seen it
thoughts I I haven't seen it um I'm not
that when it comes to like movies and
stuff I'm really not that well um well
versed in them you know uh I had a few
film classes when I was in college but
as many of you know college was decades
ago for me you
know um Elli adct there's evidence that
the government played a role in creating
anti-establishment movements like the
Beat Generation hippie movement I mean
who
cares uh that very often will we can be
like well it had this origin so
therefore it must be in the control of
these people I mean things often spiral
off into their own thing the meaning of
a movement isn't just in its its uh very
Origins because as movements they change
over time so I'm not that interested in
in that sort of thing uh Kus I recently
made a small for into blondell's action
a action in 1893 I'm guessing uh and
quite enjoyed the little I've read I
want to say thank you for your videos on
Blondell with without which I wouldn't
have known about it yeah I mean down the
line I got to start doing some core
concept videos on Blondell people have
been asking for them for a while and he
definitely deserves to be better known I
I probably wouldn't start with action
1893 because it's such a big dense book
I might begin with like um
you know history and Dogma or the
letteron Apologetics or a logic of the
moral life or one one of these other
shorter things or I don't know maybe
maybe I'll do maybe down the line I'll
do videos on the Christian philosophy
debates and I've translated some of
blondell's contributions to that I I
could do that I mean I've done readings
of them
right um elatic have you seen Carefree
wanderings videos what do you think of
his work I watch very few other people's
things um and it I often get these
different people mixed up with each
other um I may have looked at Carefree
wanderings um let's see Carefree
wanderings if he's the person who did
something recently on
stoicism um then I I I suspect that his
his work is uh not very good there was a
thing people were asking me about
recently and I was like uh yeah this is
this is actually not good at all one of
my friends reached out to me he's like
can you watch this
um I mean I I don't know I mean there's
looking at the videos that are available
there it's very much about like pop
intellectual culture isn't it um when I
see people talking about
wokeism um unless they're you know using
it um in in a very ironic way usually I
I tend to dismiss them as as not being
particularly good thinkers right so I I
don't know I I don't know enough about
him to say anything really Mark is there
any children's book you read as a kid
you remember fondly would you read them
again uh yeah and I have I have read
them again uh to my own
children
so there is a book and it's not a very
good book but it it was it was a beloved
book called B9 the hungry metal
eater and my grandma grandma Saddler um
bought me a copy and sent it to me when
I had
chickenpox Grandma Sadler unfortunately
died quite young of of cancer um I want
to say she was she died in 1977 so I was
I was uh only six or seven when she died
and um she was in her her 50s when she
died too um I remember seeing her in the
oxygen
tent anyway she sent me this book when I
had chickenpox and there's a little
inscription you know dear Gregory hope
B9 can eat up your chickenpox there was
also another really wonderful book that
I had as a child called um One Fine Day
and it's a it's a great book about this
fox who gets his tail cut off because
he's kind of a jerk he drinks up this
this woman
uh milk that she's got and she cuts his
tail off and she's like you're not
getting your tail back until I get my
pale of milk back and so now he's got to
go through all these things and and
trade this and trade that
um what else I mean you know as a kid I
read Lloyd Alexander's Chronicles of
pretty and when I was in elementary
school and loved those we had lion witch
in the wardrobe read to us in art class
when I was a kid because we had a we had
a teacher who was kind of cool with that
that sort of stuff in third and fourth
grade and uh there is there is another
book it's a child a children's book that
I didn't read as a child but it's one of
my my
favorites and it's really wonderful and
I I bought it and read it to my own
kids um and it's called the horse the
cat and the miracle and it's about this
this stable cat and a a stable horse and
a cat and their they're kind of friends
with each other although they have very
different
natures and um they they find this
golden thread that they're supposed to
follow out and roll up into a ball and
it goes across the countryside and
they're you know it's a fairy who
assigns this task to them and they go
through a lot of Adventures and a lot of
hardships and
eventually you know towards the end this
is an almost insurmountable task and you
feel despair about it and they have to
push this ball up a
Mountaintop and it's covered with like
crap from the road and um I won't tell
you what the miracle is but it's it's a
book that makes me makes me cry because
it's so good and um touches your
emotions quite well all right
um let's see here pipeline authenticity
tip tip Journal when it hurts to write
you know it's honest in the areas that
really matters I mean it could be the
case or it could just be that you've got
you've peeled one level of the onion um
I I I don't know I
mean that could could be a Criterion but
there's no like infallible Criterion
right uh Johan if if you like metal you
might really enjoy the very moving
documentary Anvil about the band of the
same name I like Anvil I haven't I
haven't watched that documentary I don't
I don't watch a lot of documentary
frankly um but I suppose I should check
it out down the line uh Gilbert do you
have any advice for conducting
conversations with people in groups it's
kind of a teaching question in other
words what gets people talking and
opening up about themselves well um I
think
that being willing to open up about
yourself in a way that is relatable and
not like look at how great I am you know
those sort of you know
I started out as a slob like you and now
I'm so much better you know that that
you see like the self-help people do if
if you don't do that and you're and like
let's say you're gonna talk about
something that's really quite sensitive
so every time that I talk about a topic
that I I approach a lot anger
understanding anger and anger management
I mention that I have I'm interested in
it because I struggled with it right and
sometimes you can say things like uh
well I I screwed up this job because of
it right and then people often do
respond to that I mean if they're if
they're decent people if they're jerks
they're probably going to use that
against you but um probably most of the
people that are coming to a group
because they're interested in like
learning something aren't like that I
mean there are some that are just there
to tooth their own horn and you do have
to deal with them too right and the way
that I deal with them is I'll say well
that's interesting but here's what we're
talking about you so you steer it back
to the the the topic under discussion
and sometimes you can say you know we
can talk about that later but right now
we're talking about this I think that
that's a useful strategy that I have
certainly used uh many
times uh Javier says why do you think
some Catholics seem to be afraid of
Blondell and call them a heretic because
they're not really Catholics they're
just ignoramuses who have believed you
know crap that they're learning from
whoever it is that they like and they're
showing a distinct lack of charity and
prudence and um spreading lies you know
um and I would include uh people like uh
gagu LR in that gagu LR condemned
Blondell admitted he didn't understand
his work that's a terrible way for a
philosopher or a theologian to to work
isn't it I mean it's a denial of of the
the requirement to be truthful so I
would say that that those people aren't
even really Catholic they're they're uh
I mean here's the thing that you find
out about Heretics right Heretics are
the ones generally who are like we are
the true Christians all the rest of you
are wrong and then the rest of the
church is like no buddy you're the one
who's wrong you know
so there we go
um let's see
[Music]
here colos is recommending spinal tap
yes I've I've I've seen that one I saw
them when they were on Saturday Night
Live uh live that that time actually and
they played big bottom and Christmas
with the
devil
um let's see Joe Adams what books have
you enjoyed not relating to philosophy I
have an entire series called worlds of
speculative fiction that would um you
could like look through them and see
which authors we've we've covered and
those would be a lot of those
books
um Zachary positive psychologists
distinguish between UD dionic and
hedonic conceptions of Happiness as well
as excellent character traits could the
field of positive psychology be a
validation of virtue ethics could be a
validation of generic virtue ethics but
Arista tilian virtue ethics doesn't need
positive psychology to validate it and
positive psychology is kind of kind of
weak stuff in my experience anyway
compared to some of the other approaches
out there I mean it's not terrible but
it's you know I mean it's relying so
much on like self-reporting and surveys
and stuff like that that from an
epistemological perspective sometimes
you're like oh really these are the
results that you say that you have you
know so all right cowboy was looking to
do a careful reading on a chapter
hopefully just a couple paragraphs of
the leviathon any sections you think
would be especially interesting to pick
apart um well I think you should read
you know book one and book two of the
whole thing I mean don't bother with
book three in book four because it's
hobb's weird biblical theology that
nobody really cares about including most
hob Scholars but um you should read
through the whole thing because
otherwise you're you're not you can't do
a close reading without reading the
entire text and situating the passage
that you're reading within the text
right um all right uh Dylan says I'm a
TA currently pursuing a master's degree
in a applied philosophy and ethics at a
university in Texas any tips for PHD
programs in today's world well I mean I
don't know what you mean by tips for PHD
programs like how to get in or what to
do once you're in a program or you know
um uh you
know expect whatever you're going to do
in the PHD program if you're going to a
different school to be quite a bit
different from whatever it was that you
were doing in the first school because
schools are all different from each
other I guess that could be uh
something uh Andre cardoso have you read
French commentators on epicus anyone in
particular calls your
attention I mean I haven't read French
thinkers who are just like going through
epictetus's discourses and engaging in
commentary uh but I don't do that with
English speakers either I read the
discourses right I have read a lot of
French philos philosophers who do talk
about epicas you know P Ado uh jacqu
shev of the air um you know those are
two people from the 20th
century um that come to mind right off
the bat and you know you if we wanted to
be kind of joking around we could say
yes Blaze Pascal because Pascal actually
talks about epicus in the pan and he
thinks that the stoics get some things
right and other things wrong um
all right
uh Ariana says what's the secret of
Plato's caves influence on subsequent
philosophical theories I don't know even
what that's referring to uh a secret of
Plato's Cave it's not something I I'm
familiar
with
um let's see elatic I mean don't you
think the philosophically speaking
mainstream Catholic papal church almost
completely straight away dogmatically
from the first thousand years of
Christianity papal
infallibility no I I I I think that's
just a bunch of word salad there quite
frankly um Cowboy just to be clear I've
just finished the Leviathan oh okay I'm
going back for an essay um okay well
that's very different right um I mean if
you're if you want something you can get
some real meat out
of I would say you know looking at the
discussion of the causes of human
conflict
before he proposes the laws of nature
right um that's that's a really
fascinating topic because Hobbs doesn't
just think it's purely strategic you
know competition and diffidence there
there's also this aspect of vanity well
what is that right how does that work
and then you got to read back a little
bit earlier into the text I mean the
laws of nature are very interesting as
well they they're articulating
essentially a hsian ethic that we
typically call contractarian but some
people have made an argument that Hobs
is in fact providing a kind of loose and
anemic ver uh
um um virtue
ethics
um so that could be interesting there's
also a discussion and this is later on
um where
he's talking about whose books should be
banned right so that could be uh quite
good to to check out um that's in book
two right uh and he also talks about
like the the the the Sovereign is the
person who should decide that sort of
thing so all right let's see who else
we've got uh because I'm gonna have to
wrap up soon I gotta get some some lunch
in me and then I've got another event to
do um
fickle Frank how would you define
friendship by your own standards I don't
really have my own standards um I I Rely
pretty heavily on I mean I'm a
philosopher so I rely on you know what's
available to me in the vast field of
philosophy and um I think that Aristotle
is right that genuine friendship because
there's different things we call
friendship
involves
[Music]
um wishing well or Desiring the good for
the other for their own sake and that
this is done reciprocally so if if it's
just me wishing you well but you don't
wish me well we don't actually have a
friendship and I think that Aristotle is
right as well in
highlighting the fact that there has to
be
interaction uh we have to know each
other and it doesn't mean we have to
like know each other in the depths of
our soul but we do have to spend some
time together I think Aristotle
you know he doesn't have any notion of
like spending time um through letters or
or virtually but I think that's that's
quite helpful
so
um let's see
here Orville in regards to Plato's
dialogues and n z thra what do you think
about teaching philosophy in the form of
a
story yeah why not you know I mean
there's lots of ways to to teach
um philosophy we've got lots of
different genres letters are another way
you know um
treates
poems it's not as if there's only one
way to do it
um let's see Ariana what books or
resources would you recommend as
introduction to philosophy H start with
Plato you know um there's a whole I've
got like a whole self-directed study set
of videos that there's a playlist you
can peruse you
know
[Music]
um looks like there's a bunch of back
and forth discussion there okay so this
is probably a good place to to wrap up
so um another good AMA a lot of good
questions about philosophy some about
some other stuff including uh popular
culture so we do these every month uh we
got some other stuff coming up this
month next weekend we're doing uh
um uh worlds of speculative fiction and
we're looking at the trilogy by NK Json
the broken Earth which is really great
stuff then we have uh the international
stoic H where I'll be speaking the
weekend after that talking about things
of beauty high and and low and then
we'll uh continue on with the
understanding
anger uh series which I didn't get to
last month we're going to talk about
asus's or esta and anger in
those works and on the way I'm also
going to be doing a live reading of HP
lovecrafts the cats of ulthar great
little short story and cautionary tale
about why you must not kill cats and um
certainly not the the little kitten of a
uh um wandering Refugee boy right all
right so I will see all of you somewhere
else down the line and uh have a great
whatever it is for for you morning
afternoon evening night and I'll see you
next
time